ich bin nicht so viel Knoblauch nehmen
warum
weil ich nicht nach Knoblauch riechen
war
weil ich noch ein Date habe mit Mord
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres Mittagessen
oder Abendessen je nachdem wann ihr es
essen möchtet dabei auch die Frage
eigentlich schon zu Beginn esst ihr
mittagsfarm oder abends warm oder sogar
zweimal warm denn ich kenne Familie da
wird zweimal warm gegessen sowas bei uns
früher wenn er mein Papa von der Arbeit
kam gab es Warmes essen mittags für uns
Kinder gab es warmes Essen also gab es
zweimal und dann gibt's aber auch
Familien da wird nur mittags warm
gegessen und abends gibt's Abendrot und
dann geht's wieder um Familien da wird
mittags nicht warm gegessen und zwar
abends warm gegessen so jetzt können wir
das gerne mal aufklären denn bei uns
gibt's
unterschiedlich manchmal gibt's
tatsächlich zweimal warmes Essen
manchmal halt nicht je nachdem wir Lust
haben wir haben da nicht so wirklich so
die feste Routine sondern ja abends
gibt's schon immer warmes essen mittags
mal so mal so naja egal jedenfalls hat
es geklärt ihr könnt mir gerne in die
Kommentare schreiben heute gibt es ein
knuspriges sesam-hähnchen dazu gibt es
eine grüne leckere Gemüsebeilage aus
Brokkoli und Edamame und kokosreis und
das ist so ein Essen was ihr innerhalb
von einer halb dreiviertel Stunde
zubereitet Zutaten bei den Zutaten
sieht's aus als wäre es viele aber es
ist immer nur weil ich alles so in
Schälchen Anrichte ansonsten sind viele
Zutaten die ihr eben Vorratsschrank habt
wie z.B Sojasoße
das sind so basic Zutaten mit denen ihr
immer etwas ganz ganz toll würzen könnt
ich fange jetzt erstmal an mit dem
Fleisch und das muss mariniert werden
und dafür nehme ich etwa 450 g
Hähnchenfleisch das habe ich bereits
gewürfelt Sojasoße etwas Honig eine
Knoblauchzehe Salz und Pfeffer den Saft
einer Limette etwas Olivenöl und später
noch sesamen das Fleisch habe ich wie
gesagt schon geschnitten
jetzt habt ihr hier die Sojasauce
den Honig
Butter hat nämlich auch noch hierher
denn das einzige was ich erstmal
weglasse ist der Sesam das heißt das
Hähnchen wird jetzt erstmal mariniert
bis low Olivenöl die Sojasauce
die ist Soße das ist so eine fertige
scharfe Soße könnt ihr gerne auch
weglassen wenn ihr keine Schärfe mögt
etwas Honig zum Abrunden
die Knoblauchzehe die halbiere ich jetzt
einfach nur damit sie den Geschmack so
ein bisschen verbreitet ich sehe es
jetzt schon kommen dass ich später auf
eine Knoblauch selber
weil ich denke es ist ein Stück Fleisch
und dann gebe ich jetzt direkt den Saft
der Limette dazu und beim Salzen könnt
ihr jetzt etwas vorsichtiger sein denn
Sojasaucen sind allgemein schon sehr
salzig aber so eine kleine Prise gebe
ich dazu und etwas Pfeffer und der
Limettensaft der rundet ist auch
geschmacklich wundervoll ab
[Musik]
das reicht
nicht dass ihr denkt ich bin krank oder
so aber ich weiß dass Sojasoße einfach
salzig ist deswegen kommt wirklich ganz
wenig Salz noch rein das lasse ich jetzt
hier kurz stehen und zeige euch schon
mal die Zutaten für den Reis und hier
habe ich 240g Basmati Reis einen halben
Teelöffel Salz 280 g Wasser und 200 g
Kokosmilch für den Reis habe ich jetzt
hier den kleinen Murat Topf der reicht
auf jeden Fall und ich habe den
Basmatireis auch bereits gewaschen Reis
sollte man immer waschen da kann immer
noch stärkere Rückstände haben und vor
allem kann er einfach verschmutzt sein
deswegen schon abwaschen dann kommt
alles in den Topf und das ist jetzt die
quellreis-methode das heißt ich habe
einen Teil Reis und zwei Teile
Flüssigkeit es gibt ja auch die
wasserreis-methode dass man quasi wie
Nudeln im Wasser kocht und später
abgießt aber ich finde die
quellreise-methode wenn man da weiß wie
das Verhältnis ist ist eigentlich immer
ganz einfach hier kommt jetzt das Wasser
dazu
und dann auch gerne schon die Kokosmilch
und dann haben wir so einen richtig
leckeren aromatischen kokosreis
[Musik]
das ist auch schon Salz dran dann kommt
das schon auf dem Herd
und dann lasse ich sie jetzt einfach
aufkochen ich passe auch auf dass es
nicht überkocht und gebt dann den Deckel
drauf und stellt dann runter auf etwas
Stufe 4 bis 5 das reicht dann auch schon
so dass er schön durchziehen kann bis er
gar ist und dann kann ich euch jetzt
noch die Gemüsebeilage zeigen die
Zutaten dafür für die Gemüsebeilage
verwende ich etwas Olivenöl eine
Knoblauchzehe etwas Ingwer etwa 400
Gramm Brokkoli 300 g marme die sind aus
dem Tiefkühlfach Sojasoße und
Cashewkerne nehme ich mal erst den
Brokkoli und hier immer mit dran denken
der Brokkoli Stiel ist essbar also
dieser Strunk ich schäle den immer
einfach
außen weg das ist sowieso holzig und das
Innere könnt ihr aber schön feinwürfeln
und dann könnt ihr das immer mitessen
also nicht verschwenden und dann
schneiden wir da so zwei drei Stückchen
und wir fahren
und ich mache es jetzt gleich so ich
habe jetzt hier noch eine Pfanne und
werde jetzt eine Pfanne fördern
verwenden das heißt da mache ich jetzt
kurz das Gemüse drin ich kann jetzt hier
auch schon mal etwas Olivenöl erhitzen
gar nicht so viel das reicht schon aus
und werde jetzt aber vorher bevor ich
den Brokkoli mache schon mal ingwer und
Knoblauch feinwürfeln
und ich muss sagen ich schneide Ingwer
immer einfach so ich schäle den auch
nicht außer er hat so harte Stellen die
kratzt sich dann weg aber ansonsten
braucht ihr irgendwann nicht schnell
einfach rein würfeln
[Musik]
da kommen jetzt die Ingwer Knoblauch und
Brokkoli Würfel in die Pfanne
das kann jetzt hier schon mal schön
angebraten werden und ich finde ja
sobald man Knoblauch und Ingwer anbrät
hat man schon so diesen schönen
asiatischen Geschmack das riecht einfach
schon perfekt und richtig gut
ist einfach so die Basis für alles und
den restlichen Brokkoli hier den teile
ich einfach in Röschen ein das finde ich
immer am schönsten wenn ihr dann noch
ein bisschen Strom habt dann den auch
einfach rein würfeln
nicht vergessen ab dem 17 Februar bin
ich jeden Freitag live bei RTL bei Let's
Dance dabei unterstützt mich dabei ich
brauche eure Anrufe und eure Stimmen der
nicht Tanz schon ganz fleißig für euch
ich liebe Brokkoli und vorhin habe ich
zum moritzer bringst du mir bitte
Brokkoli und dann kann man mit
Blumenkohl
[Musik]
und dann gebe ich jetzt hier den
Brokkoli dazu
und auch gleich
die Edamame Bohnen
ich habe kurz überlegt der die das in
der Bar Edamame die Edamame
wohnen
dann passt es schon
[Musik]
einen größeren Tropfen
nein
und dann hacke ich hier noch die Cashews
ein bisschen die kommen auch mit rein
und dürfen geröstet werden
also nicht zu klein hacken
gebe ich jetzt Etikett Schuss dazu und
dann bratet ihr das alles ruhig ein paar
Minuten an
und ich liebe Edamame weil sie wirklich
viel Omega 3 Fettsäuren enthalten viel
Vitamin C viel Vitamin E und ich finde
diese grüne Farbe in der Pfanne einfach
der Hammer ich liebe grünes Gemüse und
das solltet ihr auch tun den grünes
Gemüse ist sehr sehr gesund
und wenn ihr dann genug habt kommt jetzt
die Sojasoße dazu das ist so ein
Wundermittel
hier gibt's so einen leckeren Geschmack
dann etwas Salz und Pfeffer
und jetzt einfach drauf achten dann
einfach nicht mehr weiter garen denn der
Brokkoli muss schon noch Biss haben
also ich habe mich jetzt dazu
entschlossen wir nehmen eine weitere
Pfanne
da kommt Olivenöl rein denn darin wird
es gleich angebraten ihr könnt aber auch
Kokosöl nehmen das ist auch hochheizbar
unser Olivenöl ist es auch mich stellt
aber jetzt nicht ganz so vor jetzt ist
sondern Mittel hohe jetzt ne und dann
gebe ich meinen Sesam hier in den Teller
und ummantele jedes kleine
Fleischstückchen und nicht das
knoblauchstückchen mit Sesam und die
Soße die über bleibt die brauchen wir
gleich noch
und was ihr schon ummantelt habt könnt
ihr dann gerne anbraten
[Musik]
und dann bratet ihr die Hähnchenstücke
von allen Seiten ungefähr 5-6 Minuten an
giftig da sind und in der Zwischenzeit
ist der Reis eigentlich auch schon
fertig da habe ich den Herd schon vor 10
Minuten etwa ausgemacht also da reicht
auch meist die nachhitze gerade bei so
einem gusseisentopf weil der die Hitze
wirklich perfekt speichert ja dann ist
das Essen gleich fertig hier drin werde
ich aber gleich noch diese restliche
Soße anrühren dann habe ich nämlich noch
eine Soße und da gebe ich dann nur etwas
so ein bis zwei ist es stärker noch rein
etwas Wasser und dann habe ich wirklich
eine schöne Soße die ich darin in dem in
der Fleischpfanne anbraten und dann
aufkochen lassen kann und dann ist es
perfekt
hier sind jetzt die letzten Stückchen
und jetzt aufpassen dass auch der Sesam
hier nicht verbrennt jetzt kommt hier
die Soße rein mit Knoblauch
dann Stärke und Wasser verrühren
und einfach schön aufkochen lassen und
die Soße solltet ihr dann kurz
abschmecken wenn ihr noch etwas Salz
braucht Pfeffer oder Limettensaft
einfach dazu geben
[Musik]
dann lege ich einfach nur das Fleisch
wieder zurück dann bleibt schön warm
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier fertig gekocht und
Murat darf probieren Murat hat auch
einen Gast dabei nämlich unseren Freud
Ali
[Applaus]
ali ist mein Arzt und ab einem gewissen
Alter sollte man sich überlegen welche
Freunde in welchem Berufsgruppen man
sich auch sucht so deswegen haben
Freunde
[Gelächter]
ich mache euch jetzt mal so eine kleine
ihr wisst immer noch fotografieren
aber später kriegt ihr natürlich noch
mehr
als als Arzt möchte was dazu essen ist
gut aus also es sieht nicht nur sehr gut
aus also das sind jeder Mama
[Musik]
also unsere Kids auch
mit Sesam und da ist diese rosinsoße
drüber kann es sein
ja
du kannst ehrlich sein
[Musik]
du bist nicht mit dir verheiratet
boah und voll lecker ja vielleicht noch
ein bisschen Salz ja ich spiele in
meinem Team bisschen
Salzen weil alle immer sagen dass ich zu
viel Salze aber ich sage beim Reis
allein schon hat Salz gefehlt
aber ich finde essen muss halt stabil
sein danke danke
alles raus ich finde das richtig lecker
ohne Spaß
ich finde vor allem hat man so eine
Reisbeilage und dann viel Gemüse Fleisch
eine leckere Soße oder wirklich
da habe ich Sojasoße drin und Limetten
ingwer ist hier drin
Knoblauch und Sesam ja und ein bisschen
ich mag das nicht
meistens im Krankenhäusern kantin der
Fall ja ja ich erinnere mich daran wie
wir auf Geburtstag
dann Essen aus der Kantine in Kreißsaal
bestellt hat aber auch nur gemeckert
über das Essen
sehr lecker sehr lecker ich glaube den
Männern schmeckt ganz gut ich wünsche
euch viel Spaß beim Nachkochen schreibt
mir gerne ob ihr euch noch weitere
einfachere Rezepte wünscht und ob das
nach eurem Geschmack ist also bis zum
nächsten Mal tschüss
ich versuche immer so ein bisschen so
one Pot mäßig aber ich finde das sind so
Sachen die man schon so breiten
jetzt richtig an für die Fotos und dann
ja ich mache Reis immer ein Busreisen
dann kann ich immer sofort den Strom
ausmachen und dann zieht es nach
voll lecker ehrlich ohne Spaß ganz toll
machen ich bringe euch gleich noch mal
tschüss machs gut tschüss bleibt gesund
raus voll lecker gell
[Musik]